في ظل اتهام نفوذ المملكة
والقرار الأخير بخفض
إنتاج النفط بدفع الأسعار إلى الأعلى على
المدى القصير على الأقل ، انحياز
لروسيا ، فما ردكم على أن
المملكة العربية السعودية لا تقف إلى جانب روسيا ،
فهي تقف إلى جانب محاولة
ضمان استقرار  أسواق النفط التي
تعود بالفائدة على المستهلكين والمنتجين على حد سواء ،
لقد فعلنا ذلك لعقود من الزمن ،
حاولنا التأكد من عدم وجود
تقلبات وأسعار غير منتظمة حتى نتمكن من
الحصول على منطق عندما يتعلق الأمر بالاستثمارات
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالإقراض وعندما
يتعلق الأمر  بالنسبة للأسعار ،
تؤمن المملكة العربية السعودية بهذا الأمر بشدة ، فقد
تم اتخاذ قرار تخفيض الحصص
بالإجماع من قبل 22 دولة ،
وقد استجابت الأسواق بشكل إيجابي للغاية ،
فقد انخفض سعر النفط
فعليًا منذ الأسبوع الماضي ولم يرتفع
الرئيس جو بايدن.  قال مرارًا وتكرارًا
الآن أنه ستكون هناك عواقب
للسعودية على السعودية لهذه الصفقة دون
الكشف عن التفاصيل الآن نحن نعلم
أن العديد من أعضاء الكونجرس  وتهدد النساء
بتجميد مبيعات الأسلحة
إلى المملكة أه لسحب القوات الأمريكية
من المملكة للحد من تأثير أوبيكس
على الأسواق في المستقبل هل هذا
يقلقك ما هي المخاطر التي تنطوي عليها
هذه الإجراءات إذا كانت هذه العواقب
هذه البدائل أه نعم سأحمل
لا أستطيع الحديث عن دوافع
الدولة وراء تصريحات المسؤولين أه
ما أستطيع قوله لكم أن بيع
أسلحة دفاعية وأسلحة للسعودية
يخدم مصلحة أمريكا
ويخدم مصلحة السعودية ونوعًا
من  مصلحة الأمن والاستقرار
في الشرق الأوسط وجود
القوات الأمريكية في الشرق الأوسط
هنا منذ عدة عقود ، فهي موجودة
هنا لحماية استقرار
وأمن الشرق الأوسط
واستقرار وأمن الولايات
المتحدة.  تتمتع سان دييغو في
الولايات المتحدة بعلاقة قوية للغاية على
مدار ثمانية عقود ، فقد كانت شريكًا
وثيقًا للغاية في مكافحة التطرف
والإرهاب والحفاظ على الاستقرار
والأمن في الدفاع في الدفاع عن
المنطقة وكانا حليفين وثيقين للغاية
من الناحية الاقتصادية والتجارية
والاستثمارية ونأمل أن تستمر هذه
العلاقة ونتطلع إلى
استمرار هذه العلاقة على مدى العقود الثمانية المقبلة.
كان أعضاء oplet Plus ، ليس أقلهم
الإمارات والعراق ، يتراجعون عن
الخفض الذي لم يرغبوا فيه في رؤية
حجم العربة ولم يرغبوا في رؤية هذا
الخفض في الإنتاج يحدث عندما
تساءلوا عن توقيت هذا الخفض
بعد فوات الأوان و  بالنظر إلى التداعيات التي تشاهدها
المملكة بسمعتها على
التل في واشنطن في الوقت الحالي وهذه
الأسئلة حول العلاقة التي تمضي
قدمًا بين المملكة العربية السعودية والولايات المتحدة
عند التفكير ربما تصرف السعوديون بشكل
مختلف
، لدينا ما يحدث في المناقشات
قبل اتخاذ القرارات.  شيء
لم أكن مطلعة عليه حقًا
لأنني لم أكن في ذلك الوقت أثناء
المحادثات ولكن ما يمكنني إخبارك به  هو ما
يعتبر المحصلة النهائية كل دولة عضو
في أوبك وأوبك بلس
أيدت هذا القرار لذلك هذا ما
نذهب به أه فيما يتعلق بالمضاربة
أو التصريحات على عكس ذلك أنا لا
أشترك في هؤلاء لأنني أعتقد
أن المحصلة النهائية هي الجميع  وافق
على ذلك ، لذلك كان قرارًا بالإجماع ، لذلك
هذا قرار واحد
وفيما يتعلق ب أه التطلع
إلى الأمام ، أعتقد أننا نتطلع إلى
أسواق أكثر استقرارًا
ونتطلع إلى الأسواق التي يتم
توفيرها بشكل كافٍ ونتطلع إلى
اجتناب أه الشاذ في
الأسواق وهذا ما تفعله السعودية